le deuxième épisode de la série va donc
nous amener aujourd'hui à parler de
pétrole est en fait pétrole ça va être
au sens large les hydrocarbures
alors on va faire comme dans toute bonne
série américaine après la coupure de la
pub c'est à dire qu'on va reprendre
l'histoire là où on l'avait laissée et
là où on l'a laissé la dernière fois
c'est sûr ce petit graphique dont j'ai
essayé de vous expliquer que il résumait
finalement l'essentiel de l'aventuré
humaine claquement de l' aventure
industrielle au 19è et au 20e siècle et
qu'il était à l'origine même si vous en
rendez pas compte de l'essentiel des
avancées socioéconomiques qui vous
permettent par exemple d'être dans cette
salle à pouvoir faire des études longues
je vous ai également rappelé que cette
petite relation avait la très mauvaise
idée d'être contrainte de deux manières
la première c'est par la quantité de
ressources disponibles et la deuxième
c'est par l'effet des sous-produits de
s'être réaction donc aujourd'hui on va
passer deux heures concentrer sur la
première des deux questions c'est à dire
combien de temps est-ce que je peux
creusé à vitesse accélérée dans le sol
pour faire sortir ces fameuses
hydrocarbures qui encore une fois
approvisionne fournissent 80% de la
consommation d'électricité e d'énergie
mondiale alors pour disserter sur ce
problème on va commencer par partir la
plage ou plus exactement à côté de la
plage puisque on va reprendre l'histoire
du pétrole depuis le début
alors depuis le début l'histoire du
pétrole c'est en fait l'histoire de la
vie marine l'essentiel des gisements de
pétrole
aujourd'hui connue et c'est aussi vrai
pour les gisements de charbon mais ça
n'arrive pas par la vie marine sont le
résultat de la sédimentation d'une vie
ancienne passé et en ce qui concerne le
pétrole
il est en particulier le résultat d'un
processus de sédimentation que je vais
vous décomposez pas à ta qui concerne le
plancton qui a vécu pour l'essentiel
dans l'océan et pour une toute petite
partie il peut y avoir des fossilisation
à la suite de dépôt la cus c'est à dire
dans les lacs
donc vous avez là sous vos yeux du
pétrole faut juste attendre entre 10
millions et un milliard d'années et vous
avez du pétrole donc c'est une énergie
qui est parfaitement renouvelables à
l'échelle des temps géologiques à
l'échelle des temps qui nous intéresse
on retombe sur cette question d'ordre de
grandeur dont je vous avais parlé la
dernière fois c'est un peu moins
renouvelables et on peut même considérer
que ce n'est pas du tout cette vie
marine
vous avez à peu près 1 % de la biomasse
qui se forme dans l'océan qui va finir
par sédimenter alors que deviennent les
99% restants de landes jean pierre
foucault et bien ils sont ils retournent
dans l'océan où il allie ont en gros ils
vont servir soit à des à des macrophages
offerts à des bestioles qui se
nourrissent des cadavres y compris de
plantons soit se décomposer ce qui en
général revient à une chose puisque vous
avez toujours des bactéries donc
processus de décomposition
donc il retourne dans le cycle cours du
carbone et puis 1 1% qui va rentrer dans
un cycle long du carbone c'est à dire
qu'il va rentrer dans la partie minérale
en formation au fond de l'océan
alors on va prendre l'histoire à son
début on a donc dans les fonds
océaniques du sédiment avec deux dans
des petits si l'aide de matières
organiques ces petits filets de matières
organiques c'est donc le reste de
l'équivalent de vos cours carcasse sauf
que chez séché des micro organismes qui
ont vécu à la surface de l'océan
quelquefois dans les fonds marins
vous avez donc encore une fois le
sédiment enseignement s'excuse debout 1
ça n'est pas sans rappeler le débouchage
des toilettes quand on va faire des
carottages en fond des océans
donc c'est une espèce de boue dans l'est
dans laquelle vous avez de la matière
organique
vous avez aussi normalement a pris ou
même si vous l'avez pas appris ça vous
rappellera les vieux souvenirs qu'il
existe à la surface de la planète
un vaste mouvement de tectonique des
plaques c'est à dire que la partie
solide de la croûte crs déplace
lentement sur des parties pâteuse que
vous avez en dessous et ça à certains
endroits sacrés des mécanismes
d'enfouissement subduction
d'enfouissement vous avez ce qui était
auparavant juste sous l'océan qui se met
à s'enfouir dans les profondeurs
terrestres
quand vous vous en foutez dans les
profondeurs terrestres ou vous
rapprocher des parties chaudes de la
planète dont je vous rappelle qu'elles
sont dus à la radioactivité naturelle
des roches en fait c'est une petite
centrale nucléaire qu'on a sous nos
pieds et vous allez donc avoir la
matière organique qui va être chauffée
alors cette matière organique quand elle
est chauffée à un peu moins de 100
degrés de quelques dizaines de degrés
jusqu'à 100 degrés elle subit une
décomposition biologique
ok les bactéries qui commence à faire
miam miam et ces bactéries évacue de
l'eau et du co2 donc dans cette partie
organique l'eau et de co2 s'évacue dans
une première phase et ceux qui restent
derrière est un composé qu'on appelle du
kérogène donc céder petit filet de
matières organiques débarrasser d'eau et
d'hydrogène
et puis le sédiment lui-même il va se
compacter se solidifier et se
transformer en une roche
ça peut être par exemple du grès sap etc
qui va s'appeler la roche-mère votre
package rocher avec le sédiment avec la
partie organique qui souvent représente
2 lors du % 1 dans la roche va continuer
à s'enfuir vous allez chauffer de plus
en plus fort et cette chaleur
supplémentaire va commencer à pyrolyse
et la fraction donc là c'est plus une
dégradation bactérienne c'est une
dégradation chimiques
en fait vous allez craquer à l'intérieur
de la de la croûte terrestre
les molécules organiques longue que vous
avez dans votre sédiments et là vous
allez commencer à avoir apparition de
molécules plus légères c'est-à-dire des
hydrocarbures liquides ou gazeux du gaz
ch4 plus de l'état n'y cédera chistera
et un certain nombre d'assemblage
puisque la nature comme vous le savez à
plein d'imagination quand il s'agit de
mettre ensemble du carbone et
d'hydrogène
donc vous allez avoir des hydrocarbures
liquides ce qu'on appelle de l'huile
dans le jargon des pétroliers et du gaz
qui va être expulsé de ce truc là dans
les petits poche qui contenait la
matière organique initiale vous allez
avoir quelque chose qui va
progressivement s'enrichir en carbone
puisque l'hydrogène et
préférentiellement attaché aux fractions
légère qui vont être expulsés de ses
ports gaz et liquide et donc vous allez
avoir un truc qui ressemble de plus en
plus à du charbon
sauf que c'est pas vraiment à une veine
de charbon exploitables je sais des
petits machins qui continuent à être
disséminés dans la roche
alors ici vous avez donc une vue
d'ensemble du processus que je viens de
vous exposer
vous avez donc ici représentée par cette
flèche ce qu'on appelle la migration
primaire donc la formation du kérogène
puis l'expulsion de l'huile et du gaz
tout ça est un processus qui prend des
millions d'années puis derrière vous
avez une migration secondaire c'est à
dire que ce gaz et son pétrole qui sont
exclus
la roche-mère vous savez à migrer dans
les couches poreuse enfin s'il ya des
couche par couche pour eux ça reste de
l'armée s'il ya des couches poreuse ça
se met à migrer dans le long des couches
poreuse et éventuellement ça va se
retrouver bloqué parce qu'on appelle un
piège c'est à dire une formation
géologique qui à un moment ou à un autre
empêche la migration de l'huile et du
gaz vers la surface
vous allez donc retrouver dans ce piège
tous les sous produits de la
décomposition à laquelle on a eu à faire
c'est à dire du gaz de l'huile et de
l'eau donc un réservoir d'hydrocarbures
s'est constitué dans des proportions
variables de manière classique d'huile
de gaz et d'eau avec le gaz qui occupe
la partie supérieure l'huile qui occupe
la partie intermédiaire lots qu'il ya en
dessous voilà quelques exemples de
pièges l'exemple en haut à gauche est un
piège ou en gros vous avez tout
simplement une cloche et puis la matière
elle migre jusqu'à se retrouver coincé
sous la cloche le deuxième cas de figure
c'est vous avez une faille alors la
matière imperméable là typiquement de
l'argile par exemple est représentée ici
et puis il ya eu un glissement de
terrain qui a permis à la couche qui est
elle à devenir obstrué
7 cette partie de la caisse que cette
partie de la formation en empêchant
ainsi les produits de la décomposition
d'aller se balader ailleurs et cetera
donc l'avez vous avez les pièges de
types variés et ce que font les
pétroliers en fait quand ils cherchent
des hydrocarbures c'est d'essayer de
repérer avec une échographie bien
particulière qui leur appartient qui
s'appelle la sismique des formations
géologiques susceptibles de contenir du
pétrole en fait ce qu'ils cherchent dans
un premier temps quand il cherche du
pétrole c'est patent du pétrole que des
pièges à pétrole c'est ça qui vont
essayer de caractériser dans les images
souterraines donc là on est dans le bon
cas de figure entre guillemets c'est
celui qui va permettre de faire avancer
les avions et voitures
et puis en fait dans l'essentiel des cas
de figure on est dans le mauvais cas de
figure c'est à dire que la migration à
de la décomposition a bien lieu
la migration a bien lieu et elle se
poursuit jusqu'au sol et à ce moment
vous allez avoir les hydrocarbures qui
arrive en surface et si cette
décomposition a lieu par exemple sous le
plancher océanique dont je vous rappelle
que il couvre 70% de la surface
terrestre
eh bien vous avez des
ma nation d'hydrocarbures dans l'océan
dont on a calculé qu'en ordre de
grandeur s'était considérablement
supérieur aux marées noires qui nous
arrive de sûr évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus diluées dans l'océan donc ça fait
beaucoup moins de dégâts
les marées noires sont très concentrés
sur des petites surfaces donc on s'en
rend beaucoup plus content mais le
dégazages d'hydrocarbures par les fonds
marins à cause de ce processus
parfaitement naturel est quelque chose
qui met dans l'océan des quantités
d'hydrocarbures beaucoup plus importante
que les marées noires coach et diluée ça
n'aura manqué qu'une personne donc dans
la majeure partie du temps ça va
jusqu'au sahara jusqu'au sol ça finit
par se dégrader et la dégradation là
elle redevient bactérienne alors dans un
premier temps il ya l'évaporation des
composés les plus volatils et puis le
reste mais éventuellement ait mangé par
les bactéries
quand cette migration à elio ya pas trop
longtemps et que l'accumulation près du
sol se fait dans des sables et bien donc
vous avez les éléments volatils qui s'en
vont ils vous restent dans les sables
des bitumes et ça c'est typiquement le
processus qui a conduit à la formation
des sables bitumineux de l'athabasca au
canada dont vous êtes est entendu parler
dans l'état d'alberta et bien c'est très
exactement ça c'est à dire que c'est du
pétrole plus vieux que le pétrole
d'accord les sables bitumineux de
l'alberta
ce sont des hydrocarbures qui ont perdu
la fraction la plus volatile
il vous reste que des chaînes carbonées
longue dans cette affaire qui sont entre
médias du sable et ce genre de truc
s'exploite beaucoup plus comme du
charbon que comme du pétrole
ça c'est que je peux exploiter aussi
comme du pétrole mais ça c'est soit
surtout comme ducharme en gros ce que je
vous ai expliqué là c'est la satanée
encore que la première partie du
processus
votre réservoir de pétrole une fois
qu'il est formé dans les profondeurs du
sol et bien l'aventuré recommence même
motif même punition la tectonique des
plaques ne s'est pas arrêté donc votre
réservoir et recommence craque à être
entraîner inexorablement vers les
profondeurs comme la victime dans la
piscine dans tout bon film d'horreur qui
se respecte donc vous avez là le
mouvement général qui va être de
nouveaux imprimés aux réservoirs
d'hydrocarbures est à nouveau entraîner
vers les profondeurs le contenu du
réservoir va chauffer parce que vous
vous rapprochez de la source de chaleur
et ça ça va induire un craquage
secondaire après le craquage primaire
que vous avez eue dans la roche mère
dans la formation des hydrocarbures et
le réservoir va s'enrichir en gaz
s'enrichir en composés carbonés
solide et s'appauvrir en hydrocarbures
liquides en général c'est ça qui se
passe donc plus vous allez profond et
plus la fraction de gaz va être
importante dans le réservoir
d'hydrocarbures que vous alliez ceci
vous explique pourquoi dans
l'exploration pétrolière
quand les pétroliers commence à explorer
un endroit ils sont surtout intéressés
par les réservoirs qui sont situés pas
trop loin du de la surface parce que
c'est cela qui vont contenir les
hydrocarbures liquides
quand ils vont chercher plus bas il
trouve toujours des hydrocarbures s'il
en trouve mais la proportion de gaz
augmente et pendant longtemps il faut se
rappeler d'une chose c'est que pendant
longtemps les pétroliers avait horreur
de trouver du gaz ne savais pas quoi en
faire
tant qu'on n'a pas trouvé que le gaz
c'était merveilleux pour faire la
cuisine et pour faire tourner les
centrales électriques
le gazon n'en avais pas envie à tel
point que dans une bonne partie des
gisements pétroliers ou en trouver du
gaz dissous dans l'huile quand on veut
remonter à la surface et quelques
dizaines d'années le gazon trouvé rien
de mieux à faire que de laisser partir
dans l'eure et dans les meilleurs des
cas de brûler sur place
mais c'était ça qu'on en sait on ne le
compte ne l'utilisait pas tout
simplement parce que les infrastructures
pour transporter du gaz sont plus
capitalistiques que les infrastructures
pour transporter du pétrole donc le gaz
ont laissé partie la donne un tout petit
peu changé
donc vous avez ici quelque chose qui
vous donne le j'allais dire le
l'évolution générale de cette affaire ce
graphique il est aussi tiré du diagramme
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure la
dune et si tu pars donc là où je vous ai
montré un diagramme et là aussi je vous
recommande très chaudement d'aller pour
ceux que ça intéresse d'aller visiter ce
site qui est un site d'un enseignant
canadien qui est remarquablement bien
fait sur les questions de géologie si
vous avez un si vous avez un peu de
temps à perdre sur internet
c'est un site absolument extraordinaire
voilà donc ça c'est le styliste c'est
l'histoire générale
alors maintenant on va reparler d'ordre
de grandeur si on essaye de faire un
inventaire à la louche de la quantité
totale de carbone d'origine organique
on va retrouvé enfoui dans la croûte
terrestre vous avez ici quelque chose
qui vous donnent des ordres de grandeur
donc la quantité totale de kérosène
c'est-à-dire le sédiment pas encore
pyrolyse et dans les premières centaines
ou les premiers milliers de mètres de la
surface terrestre et qui résultent de la
sédimentation du plancton
c'est de l'ordre comme vous pouvez le
voir la de 10 puissance s'est-on
de carbone évidemment pour l'ensemble de
la planète et puis après vous voyez que
le gaz et le pétrole qui se sont formées
à partir de ce qu'ils reviennent
et bien c'est en gros un cent millième
de ce kérosène d'accord donc le
rendement pour aller du kérogène d'air
le pétrole c'est du 10 - cinq autocars
extraordinaire si un jour vous êtes
embauché dans une industrie et que tout
ce que vous arrivez à faire un moment ça
lui dit - cinq en face à des pointes
forme en sait beaucoup de valeur à
l'arrivée ne vous en voudra un tout
petit peu et c'est donc vous voyez le la
chaîne général ici le charbon est un
terreau gènes d'un genre très
particulier qui a aussi été pyrolyse et
il se trouve que au lieu que la matière
organique initial qui a permis
l'apparition d'hydrocarbures alors le
charbon et éolienne pas 3 pc en
hydrocarbures mois ci quand même parce
que c'est quand même du charbon ou
d'hydrogène avec des pas votre truc
m'enfin c'est avant tout du charbon et
d'hydrogène
le charbon est un résidu d'êtres vivants
terrestre et j'allais dire solide entre
guillemets et concentré donc en fait
c'est le résidu fossiles de plantes qui
ont vécu à l'ère du carbonifère kalemie
française a bien fait son travail donc
employait 250 il ya 300 millions
d'années et ses plantes là elles ont
exactement comme pour le plancton
fossilisés sous la croûte terrestre
elles ont été pyrolyse et l on produit
du pétrole et du gaz elles ont produit
du pétrole et du gaz exactement de la
même manière et il est resté sous forme
exploitable
parce que avec des veines qui peuvent
faire plusieurs mètres de hauteur
quelque chose qui s'appelle du charbon
le méthane qui a été produit lors du
processus de pyrolyse reste parfois
emprisonnés dans le charbon en question
c'est grisant le grisou c'est le méthane
qui a été formé par cette matière
organique
lors de sa pyrolyse et qui est resté
prisonnier du charbon c'est à dire
prisonnier du résidu solide dont ils
auraient dû s'échapper ou dont il s'est
échappé quand il fait un gisement alors
maintenant on va rentrer un tout petit
peu dans la question de la nomenclature
qui est un truc absolument indéniable
pour le profane absolument indéniable
pour l'élu absolument indéniable pour
les lecteurs et absolument indéniable
pour n'importe qui qui fait de la
politique publique alors que vous allez
voir qu'une bonne
des malheurs qui vont nous arriver dans
les quelques décennies qui viennent sont
le fruit d'un regrettable malentendu
sémantique qui consiste à exprimer les
réserves pour personne ne touche que ça
dure est en année de consommation
on va essayer d'y voir un tout petit peu
plus clair là je vous rappelle
simplement ce que je viens de vous dire
donc un réservoir de pétrole c'est
renouvelables à l'échelle de la centaine
de millions d'années
en pratique un réservoir de pétrole
ça ressemble pas vraiment à une
baignoire c'est un morceau de caillou
avec du pétrole dedans c'est ça un
réservoir de pétrole
je suis désolé j'ai pas d'échantillons
sur moi mais peut-être que d'autres
enseignants viendront dans cette école
avec des échantillons de réservoirs de
pétrole si vous en avez qui travaille
chez total pour leur demander d'amener
un morceau de carottes et ils en ont
plein repos et vous verrez que un
réservoir de pétrole c'est un bout de
caillou faire bout de caillou est dedans
il ya typiquement de quelques pour cent
à quelques dizaines de pourcents de
pétrole or quelques dizaines de pourcent
en serrant jackpot
le cas de figure standard c'est que j'en
avais 5% 10% voilà plus de traces
brunâtres quand vous regardez ce truc un
bon ça c'est quelque chose que je vous
ai déjà dit et enfin il ya quelque chose
de complémentaire que je vous ai pas
encore dit c'est que dans le kérogène
vous avez ce qu'on appelle les schistes
les schistes bitumineux alors les sables
bitumineux
c'est du pétrole plus vieux que le
pétrole ça s'exploite il faut dépenser
beaucoup d'énergie pour transformer ces
molécules carbonées longue en
hydrocarbures liquides que vous avez
l'habitude d'utiliser légère mais ça
c'est exploite les schistes bitumineux
malgré qu'on utilise bitumineux dans les
deux cas de figure c'est en pratique du
kérogène donc c'est quelque chose qui
n'a pas encore suivi de pyrolyse ça veut
dire que pour exploiter ces
hydrocarbures là d'un genre particulier
il faut non seulement creuser sous terre
non seulement ressortir c'est la
fraction organique qui est quelquefois à
quelques pour cent lorsque vous extrayez
mais faut finir la pyrolyse à la main
donc il faut amener plein de chaleur
pour finir de pyrolyse est ce que vous
avez extrait est donc le rendement
énergétique de schistes bitumineux est
souvent inférieure à 1
en d'autres termes vous devez investir
plus de 1 kilowatt heure dans
l'exploitation que dans l'énergie que
pourrait pour récupérer un kilowattheure
d'huile de schiste
donc ça n'est pas avec la définition que
nous allons voir ensuite une réserve
c'est une ressource
elle est la plus forte si on veut ça
n'est pas une réserve et on va voir la
différence entre les deux
alors avant de voir la différence entre
les deux on va voir juste deux points
sur ces fichus réservoir je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que la manière dont les
pétroliers opérait pour essayer de
trouver le pétrole d'abord il commençait
pas refaire la même chose que ce qu'on
fait à une femme enceinte c'est à dire
une échographie alors l'échographie ça
s'appelle la sismique dans le jargon des
pétroliers c'est à dire que l'on va
envoyer une onde de choc à partir de la
surface de la planète et on va voir
comment ça se réfléchit sur les sous
couches à partir de ça on essaye de
repérer à la fois la présence de liquide
et la formation géologique
s'il ya quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas compris qu'on ne sait pas la peine
de demander ensuite un donc vous vous
essayez de comprendre si un il ya du
liquide sous sol et 2 cya la présence de
quelque chose qui peut ressembler à un
piège géologique mais la preuve ultime
que ya bien du pétrole c'est de faire un
trou d'accord ça dès qu il n'y a que ça
comme preuve ultime alors la première
question où est ce que je dois le faire
et la deuxième question c'est se doit en
faire combien pour avoir une idée de ce
que contient mon réservoir parce que je
vous rappelle encore une fois qu'un
réservoir si un bout de caillou et en
voici un exemple modélisés voilà ça
c'est un réservoir ça ressemble pas
vraiment une baignoire
ça ressemble pas vraiment un réservoir
de voiture c'est un bout de caillou dans
lequel vous avez d'huile vous voyez que
la fraction de la roche poreuse dans
laquelle vous avez l'huile c'est quelque
chose qui a une forme très disco revenus
et quand vous faites un trou ici et que
vous trouvez du pétrole et que vous
faites un trou ici et vous en trouvez
pas va vous voyez qu avec deux trous
seulement vous n'êtes pas en mesure de
savoir quelle est la taille de votre
réservoir à combien du nil est
susceptible de contenir
alors prenons l'actualité récente encore
qui va me servir est ce que certains
d'entre vous entendu parler des
découvertes récentes au large du brésil
bon et bien au large du brésil sur une
formation géologique qui fait des
dizaines de kilomètres de long si ce
n'est la centaine de kilomètres de long
pour maman on a fait six puits
d'exploration
6 pardon non mais ce qui veut dire que
l'on sait pas ce qu'il ya pour
l'industrie ces quelques dizaines de
millions $ déjà mais ça veut dire
surtout que c'est pas avec six puits
d'exploration que vous avez une barre
d'erreur sur la quantité de pétrole dans
ce réservoir qui est de quelques
dizaines de pourcents aux mamans vous
êtes encore dans le main à 10
voilà donc c'est un exemple typique où
le journal a dit y attend très bon
journal les échos pourrait me donner
en fait vous savez pas ce qu'il ya pour
le moment il ya un potentiel éventuel
c'est comme ça qu'il faut voir donc il
faut faire des trous il faut en faire un
certain nombre
et quand vous faites un trou ici et un
trou là et que vos deux trous sont
positifs bah c'est pas nécessairement
que ça communique de bout en bout
c'est pas nécessairement que la
distribution de luynes va être partout
la même le long du réservoir et c'est
donc encore une fois ce que vous avez
comme pétrole sous terre c'est une
science qui est loin d'être facile et il
ya 1,2 mais je vous citerai l'expression
tout à l'heure mais il ya un de mes amis
qui est géologue pétrolier qui explique
que de savoir combien de pétrole
extractible quand on se bat là quelque
part ça équivaut à avoir un hangar dont
on fait le tour et donc on regarde par
le trou de la serrure
il faut derrière devine exactement ce
qui est dedans c'est à peu près ça
l'exercice qui consiste à quantifier de
manière précise les quantités de pétrole
sous terre alors maintenant on va parler
nomenclature parce que vous avez beau
être dans une école scientifique
le français ont fait le français les
maths souvent c'est du français
le français a toute son importance dans
cette affaire et il faut bien comprendre
quels sont les définitions qu'on
manipule ya sous terre à cause des
processus de formation dont je viens de
vous parler du pétrole qui est du
pétrole qu'on appelle en place ce
pétrole en place s'appelle une ressource
quand on parle de ressources dans le
jargon pétroliers on ne dit rien sur son
extractives ilité on est juste qu'il est
là encore il peut être extractives ou
pas extractible on va voir dans quelles
conditions donc la ressource c'est le
pétrole en terre la ressource
encore une fois on ne dit rien sur son
extractives ilité cette ressource
elle dépend qualitativement et tout le
jeu est de savoir si quantitativement on
arrive avant les idées claires du volume
de la roche réservoir dont je vous ai
montré avec la l'image précédente que
souvent ça avait une fois une forme
extrêmement biscornu donc de savoir
voilà on est quoi dans la sphère
occident brin donc savoir quel est le
volume exact c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué ça va dépendre de la porosité
parce que pour un même volume de roche
il est évident que si vous avez des très
gros trou
ou des tout petits trous vous n'allez
pas avoir exactement la même quantité
d'huile en classe ça va dépendre de la
distribution d'huile à l'intérieur des
ports et là aussi si vous allez voir une
carotte
vous vous rendez compte que lino mot
gênés it est reine dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire que la concentration
d'huile peut très rapidement variés à
l'échelle de la dizaine de centimètres
ou la vingtaine de centimètres il est
pas rare d'avoir des réservoirs dont
l'épaisseur et quelques dizaines de
centimètres seulement voilà ça peut
varier au milieu solide entre donc ça va
c'est très très variable et enfin ça va
dépendre aussi de la viscosité de
l'huile exactement l'extractive ilité va
dépendre de la viscosité une ressource
elle n'est pas nécessairement découverte
une ressource avait pas nécessairement
découverte
donc quand on découvre du pétrole en
fait on découvre son existence mais on
ne crée pas alors ça peut vous paraître
tout con ce que je vous dis en attendant
vous pouvez pas savoir le nombre
d'économistes qui font leurs calculs
en supposant que quand on découvre le
pétrole on crée on le crée dans une
catégorie particulière qui s'appelle les
réserves mais on ne crée pas
physiquement on ne fait que constater
qu'il existe enfin le gisement une fois
qu'il ait découvert il peut rentrer dans
trois catégories
il peut être en cours d'exploitation
c'était il ya déjà des trous dedans
quiconque le pétrole tels des shadoks
il peut être en cours de développement à
ce moment ça veut dire qu'on a prévu de
mettre des trous dedans et pompé tels
les shadoks
ou bien il peut être rien de tout ça
c'est à dire que le pétrole est là et on
considère que pour le moment où on n'a
pas le temps ou c'est pas rentable où on
n'a pas la technologie pour où on n'a
pas les bons hommes pour etc
donc il peut y avoir trois catégories en
exploitation il ya déjà du pétrole qui
sort avec les shows tation commercial en
développement il est prévu d'en faire
une exploitation commerciale
ou bien on laisse la de côté
tranquillement ça c'est quelque chose
que je vous ai déjà dit mais je le
répète encore une fois
en gros ce qui a exactement dans un
réservoir de pétrole
vous allez le savoir à la fin de la vie
du réservoir vous le saurez pas au début
et en particulier au début de
l'exploration c'est difficile d'avoir
les idées claires
on va passer maintenant des ressources
aux réserves alors les réserves c'est un
mot vous avez tous vu dans journal vous
pouvez si vous avez des journalistes
dans vos relations lors
la question de savoir combien
connaissent la définition d'une réserve
dont ils parlent à tout bout de champ et
je peux vous dire que si vous en trouvez
un sur dix livres vous avez de la chance
un point qui sait ce que c'est sauf les
quelques uns qui sont éventuellement
spécialisés alors une réserve ça une
définition très précise dans la majeure
partie des pays pétroliers et en plus
certains d'entre eux ne compte même pas
comme ça c'est la fraction de la
ressource en place contenus dans des
réservoirs qui sont en exploitation ou
en développement donc ça ne concerne pas
les réservoirs dans lesquels on n'a pas
de projets de développement à bref délai
ou qui ne sont pas en exploitation donc
c'est la fraction de la ressource
contenu dans un réservoir en
exploitation ou en développement qui est
extractible de manière certaine
alors ce avec la certitude déjà huit
secondes met donc avec une probabilité
d'extraction supérieur à 90% aux
conditions techniques et économiques du
moment
en d'autres termes avec ce que ça ferme
et ingénieurs avec le prix du baril
actuelle sur le marché
je suis absolument certain de pouvoir
faire sortir au moins tant du réservoir
en question c'est ça la définition de la
réserve prouvée dans le jargon
pétroliers vous comprenez donc que c'est
quelque chose qui va dépendre de
l'évaluation de la taille du réservoir
donc quand vous vous rendez compte ex
post que votre réservoir
il est plus important physiquement que
l'idée que vous en aviez mécaniquement
savourer évalue vos réserves et quant à
linverse vous vous rendez compte qu'une
partie du réservoir ou pensez vous avez
du pétrole en fait vous avez de la
flotte ou d'huile de vidange et bien à
ce moment ça vous diminue mécaniquement
vos réserves savary avec les progrès
techniques
si aujourd'hui vous savez avec les
aspirateurs particulier dont on dispose
extraire 30% du pétrole dans une roche
de porosité donné avec une viscosité
données bah si vous inventer un
aspirateur qui permet de passer à 35 %
vous augmenter mécaniquement la fraction
de pétrole extractible sans avoir rien
toucher du reste c'est quelque chose qui
va varier avec le prix mais sur un
réservoir donné assez peu ce qui va se
passer avec le prix c'est que si le prix
de la ressource est suffisamment élevée
ça vous ouvre à l'exploitation
commerciale des réservoirs idents
tissier dans lesquelles s'était trop
onéreux avant d'aller chercher le
pétrole parce que c'est en zones
polaires et vous plais qu'il faut payer
des gens comme vous décembre royal pour
qu'ils acceptent d'aller s'enquiquiner
encore à douchez pas ou alors qu'il
pourrait très bien rester à faire de la
finance à paris donc il faut les payer
cher pour qu'ils acceptent d'aller
encore âge et si le pétrole est pas
assez cher sur le marché va vous n'avez
pas encore un jeu voilà donc il ya des
deux le prix conditionne l'accessibilité
d'un certain nombre de réserves voire
par contre sur un réservoir d'eau n'est
donc qu'une fois qu'on a trouvé les
pingouins pour allier encourage la
fraction supérieure qu'on est capable
d'extraire à partir du moment où le prix
monte n'est pas très élevé vous avez une
élasticité au prix qui est faible sur un
réservoir donné et qui par contre peut
être significatif sur l'ensemble des
ressources accessibles à la surface de
la planète et j'y viendrai un peu plus
tard et enfin tout le reste est en
constant ça diminue avec le temps à
partir du moment où votre réservoir vous
savez d'entrée de jeu il ya dedans comme
pétrole à partir du moment où le prix ne
varient pas à pas et ses bas plus vous
qu'on paie moyen reste encore donc la
réserve prouvée contenu dans un
réservoir d'eau n'est digne et que le
temps jusqu'à maintenant il est évident
que à peu près personne n'a compris
qu'on avait c'est quatre paramètres de
réévaluation des réserves et bien
évidemment ça augmente avec les
découvertes
quand vous découvrez du pétrole va vous
créez un nouveau réservoir si vous le
développer et que vous l'exploiter bien
évidemment vous allez aussi augmenter
les réserves
après donc là on était dans les réserves
prouvées après vous avez une notion qui
absolument majeur en jargon pétrolier
qu'on appelle les réserves ultimes alors
les réserves ultimes c'est l'ensemble de
ce qui peut sortir la croûte terrestre
le présent comme définition ça revient à
dire que c'est l'intégrale entre -1
filles et plus l'infini de la production
pétrolière
c'est ça les réserves ultimes la quasi
totalité des gens qui ont fait des
pronostics sur la production pétrolière
futur
on travaillait non pas sur les a
retrouvés dans tout le monde se
tamponnent mais sur les réserves ultimes
corse et les réserves ultimes qui compte
alors à partir du moment où vous enlevez
l'adjectif prouver ultime dont vous
raconte si c'est parce que vous avez
besoin de place pour tenir un article de
journal
déjà vous êtes à peu près assuré vous
emmêler les pinceaux
les réserves ultimes se décompose en
deux morceaux ce qu'on a déjà extrait ça
c'est absolument sûr que cette
extractives et puis ceux qui restent à
extraire d'accord dans ce qui reste à
extraire vous allez voir que il n'ya pas
que ce qu'il ya dans les réserves
prouvées et enfin quelque chose qui peut
vous paraître très étonnant mais comme
disait l'autre et pourtant elle tourne
c'est que les réserves dans un réservoir
données ne sont connues avec certitude
qu'une fois que l'aller l'histoire est
finie
donc il ya une réévaluation permanente
des réserves parce que avec le temps on
connaît de mieux en mieux l'objet auquel
on s'intéresse donc le grand paradoxe
c'est que ce qui va vraiment sortir du
réservoir vous le savez avec certitude
qu'une fois que vous fermez tous les
puits et vous dites je m'arrête
vous êtes sûr que vous auriez répand
alors si je résume tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter et encore une fois ça
peut vous paraître un peu austère un peu
aride mais je vous assure que c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
indispensable pour bien comprendre qu'il
va suivre
je parle des du pétrole mais c'est
valable aussi pour le gaz et pour le
charbon
j'ai des réserves ultimes qui est lent
ce qui constitue l'ensemble de ski et
extractives je vais donc y trouver ce
que j'ai déjà sortis et ce qui n'est pas
encore sorti non ce n'est pas encore
sorti je vais avoir les réserves
prouvées
ça c'est la fraction de ce qui n'est pas
encore sorti que je vous garantis là sur
facture paris ma retraite dessus que ça
va sortir de toute façon et le reste est
dans le reste vous allez trouver ce qui
reste à développer ce qui reste à
découvrir ce qui reste à réévaluer voilà
ce que vous avez trouvé
c'est ce que les fans de etc ce qui veut
dire que les réserves ultimes qui par
définition ne varie pas puisque c'est
l'intégrale entre moins affiliées plus
l'infini c'est intemporel
les réserves ultimes 1 j'insiste là
dessus c'est intemporel elle inclut par
construction les découvertes à venir
donc quand les pétroliers qui travaille
sur les réserves ultimes vous dise je
pense que la production va plafonner à
tel moment sur la base de calculs faits
sur les réserves ultimes ce calcul
intègre par la force des choses les
découvertes qu'on peut encore faire
aujourd'hui au large du brésil au
kazakhstan sous le pôle nord il n'y a
pas de pétrole soit dit en passant
teyran ça inclut les découvertes à venir
c'est juste une question d'ordre de
grandeur
alors simplement pour évacuer ce point
là les découvertes ont été faites leur
récemment au large du brésil
on parle de dizaines n'importe quoi
entre 3 et 30 milliards de barils les
réserves prouvées actuelle céline
milliards de barils et les ultimes
restantes c'est pour le vendeur 2500
questions suivantes
c'est pas ça qui va changer les ordres
de grandeur alors maintenant j'ai
découvert un gisement dans mon jugement
j'ai une incertitude sur sa taille j'ai
une incertitude sur sa viscosité la
viscosité j'ai une incertitude sur la
porosité g etc
et puis j'ai embauché un ingénieur des
mines de paris à qui j'ai demandé
d'aller travailler sur le gisement en
question que je pose la question que je
paye fort cher outrageusement cher je
lui dis combien est-ce qu'il ya de
pétrole là dedans alors mon ingénieur
des mines il va se dire bah voilà il ya
entre temps étant en ce qui concerne la
porosité temps et en ce qui concerne le
volume etc
il va faire une première réponse il va
me dire je suppose que tous les
paramètres sont bas de la fourchette
je suis aux mines du volume aux mines de
la porosité au mit au match de la
viscosité aux mines de la pression au
micro et c'est le minimum qui devrait
sortir sept ans après il dit l'idée que
je perde sur tous les tableaux
et quand même assez improbable donc
statistiquement il ya bien quelques
trucs sur lequel je vais être un peu au
dessus et à ce moment il va me dire
voilà ce sur quoi je prends les paris
ils assurent ma question ma retraite à
moi c'est que ya au moins temps qui va
sortir c'est le prouver donc c'est un
petit peu plus optimiste que tous les
paramètres au minimum et une diva voilà
ça c'est ce que j'appelle les réserves
prouvées il à sortir au moins tant de du
truc je suis en train de regarder
après il peut dire tous les paramètres
peuvent être dans à la moyenne et à ce
moment il me sort non pas le prouver
mais beaucoup plus que le prouver il me
sort en moyenne 1,7 fois le prouver donc
au moment où je découvre un gisement où
je le mets en production ce que je
déclare comme réserves prouvées c'est
toujours moins statistiquement que ce
qui va sortir la réévaluation des
réserves en cours d'exploitation et a
simplement dû au fait que j'ai été trop
conservateur sur les paramètres
techniques parce que comme tout
ingénieur
il respecte pas envie de me faire
engueuler par votre chef donc si vous
lui promet t2 alors qu' à finir par
sortir à vous fait dire et si vous lui
prométhéen avec le finir par sortir 2
vous avez une augmentation donc là vous
allez faire exactement comme tout le
monde dans un cas de figure identique
c'est-à-dire que vous avez commencé par
dire oh oh je vous garantis qui au moins
on va faire les calculs économiques en
supposant une sorte u16 et rentable à ce
prix là bas on y va puis après tout
restait du grand après on peut gagner au
loto lundi mardi mercredi jeudi et
vendredi c'est à dire avoir tous les
paramètres qui sont au contraire du bon
côté de la fourchette et à ce moment
vous avez le plus haut possible de ce
qui peut sortir des prés du max de ce
qui peut sortir
donc en gros avec des découvertes
données vous avez trois types de
réserves que vous pouvez avancer les
réserves prouvées
donc c'est ce qui va sortir avec
certitude ce que vous appelez les
réserves 2p c'est à dire ce qui est le
plus probable en termes de fractions
extractible d'accord c'est la fraction
extractives la plus probable
et enfin vous avez le 3 p c'est à dire
le max de ce qui peut sortir ces trois
c1 p2p 3 pc le plus conservateur le plus
probable le plus optimiste
alors une fois que je vais raconter tout
ça on va commencer l'histoire de
l'aventuré pétrolière de l'humanité avec
cette très belle courbe qui a été publié
par un groupe écologiste bien connu qui
s'appelle exxon donc c'est pour ça que
lacombe et on perd et cette courbe avec
la sémantique que je vous ai appris
maintenant apriso de pardon elle retrace
l'histoire des découvertes de pétrole
mais c'est les découvertes de paix c'est
à dire que c'est au fil des années la
fraction la plus probable du pétrole
extractible de ce qui a été découvert
l'année en question
cette heure je répète c'est clair
chaque année on va donc découvrir des
formations géologiques qui s'appelle les
réservoirs et dans ces formations
géologiques on va dire le pétrole
extractives le plus probable de ce
réservoir s'étend et c'est ce temps
qu'on va reporter sur cette courbe c'est
pas le volume du réservoir
ça n'est pas les réserves prouvées c'est
ce que j'appelle les réserves 2p c'est à
dire ceux qui a une chance sur d'autres
sortir et statistiquement c'est ça qui
va finir par sortir en moyenne d'un
réservoir d'eau n'est pris au hasard
la réserve voire données non mais de de
l'encens des réservoirs d'eau donc ici
vous avez les découvertes de la fraction
extractible la plus probable des
découvertes de l'année est en fait plus
exactement c'est une troupe qui a été
dit c'est sur cinq ans dont vous n'avez
pas les découvertes annuel vous avez une
moyenne mobile sur cinq ans et alors
vous vous rendez compte d'une chose en
regardant ce truc là c'est que les
découvertes mondiales de pétrole ou plus
exactement la fraction récupérables des
découvertes mondiales de pétrole n'ont
pas cru jusqu'à la semaine dernière
elles n'ont même pas cru jusqu'à l'année
dernière elles n'ont même pas crû depuis
que vous êtes né elle était déjà en
décroissance très forte au moment où
vous êtes né puisque elles sont passées
par un maximum pile de l'année de ma
naissance ou presque c'est à dire ya 45
ans et les réserves ultimes donc le
pétrole extractible globale sur la
planète c'est comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure
l'intégrale de cette courbe ou plus
exactement la valeur la plus probable
des réserves ultimes c'est l'intégrale
de cette courbe encore la valeur la plus
probable des victimes c'est l'intégrale
c'est con donc au début de la partie de
monopoly qui s'appelle civilisation
industrielle de l'humanité on a ça dans
notre garde-manger et vraisemblablement
pas beaucoup plus alors en fait si je
reprends l'histoire et que je la
prolonge un tout petit peu voilà une
cour publiée par un autre groupe écolo
bien connu qui appelle shell échelle
vous a donné ici à la fois les
découvertes annuel et la moyenne alors
là pour le coup elle dit c'est sur 20
ans et en gros à partir de cette courbe
qui vous représente la valeur la plus
probable
je reprends mon raisonnement tout à
l'heure pas de chance on ne sait pas
faire sortir mieux que le prouver de
tout ce qu'on a dit de tout ce qu'on a
découvert voilà le volume global de
pétrole récupérables sur terre on est
dans la norme statistiques dont qui sort
de n'importe quel réservoir la valeur la
plus probable des réserves 2p voilà ce
qu'on a comme pétrole à notre discours
mission on pourrait éventuellement avoir
ça là c'est le coup de chance c'est à
dire de chaque réservoir
on sait faire sortir beaucoup plus que
ce qu'on considère comme étant le plus
probable aujourd'hui donc il faut
retenir cette idée que le pétrole est
disponible le pétrin attractifs sur
terre à disponible en quantité finie ça
vous le saviez déjà même si vous en avez
pas nécessairement conscience tous les
jours et que on a maintenant c'est
surtout ça le point important
on a maintenant une idée raisonnable
parce que vous voyez que les découvertes
décline depuis 45 ans et que quand vous
demandez aux experts du secteur il vous
explique pas que ça s'apprête à remonter
à l'avenir là vous voyez que shell vous
dis ben là on est dans la queue de lagos
yann donc ça va continuer à descendre
encore et encore et encore et encore et
voilà avec des découvertes qui vont
rester
vous voyez ici ils vous disent que dans
le dans la partie descendante vous allez
encore faire de temps en temps des
découvertes annuel à quelques dizaines
de milliards de barils typiquement ce
qu'on vient de découvrir au large du
brésil
mais vous êtes dans la partie
descendante de la courbe des découvertes
donc ce que ce que le message des
opérateurs pétroliers aujourd'hui est
très clair c'est le volume global de
pétrole extractible on commence à le
servir en ordre de grandeur
par ailleurs vous vous rappellerez
probablement d'un très beau théorème de
maths que moi j'ai eu à démontrer en
taupe et puis même que je sais encore le
démontrer
qui vous dit qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez une fonction positive et
intégrables dont l'intégrale entre moins
finie et plus l'infini à une bande
supérieure alors vous pouvez démontrer
que cette fonction en moyenne par 2 0 à
moins l'infini termine à 0 à + l'infini
et passe par un maximum entre les deux
si j'applique ça à la production
pétrolière comme la production
pétrolière cumulées ne peut en aucun cas
dépasser les réserves ultimes par
définition puisque les réserves ultimes
c'est l'intégrale de -1 feely a plus
limpide la production est bien ma
production pétrolière qui était nul à
moulins fini ça c'est facile à montrer
sera du la plus infinie et va passer par
un maximum entre les deux en d'autres
termes le pic de production du pétrole
est une entité mathématiquement certaine
le pic de production du gaz est
mathématiquement certain le pic de
production du charbon est
production de n'importe quel inra
métalliques dont la nature a reçu un
stock au moment de la formation de la
terre
issu comme vous le savez des étoiles qui
était de la génération qui ont précédé
le soleil qui a précédé le soleil il est
ce qu'il est le pink et peut-être
pendant trois millions d'années ou pour
la semaine prochaine mais il existe il
existe d'accord et vous allez voir que
la notion à côté de laquelle tous les
journalistes sont passées jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est ça qui va faire
votre g et le mien aussi
c'est que on a confondu des années
réserve strycova n'est jamais exprimé
une réserve remanier sa s'exprimant
mètres cubes sa section entonnant ce que
vous voulez mais pas en années avec
l'autre qui est économiquement important
qui est la date du pic
parce que c'est ça qui est
économiquement important mais j'y
reviendrais tout à l'heure avant ça il
va falloir des mines est un élément
supplémentaire qui est une question très
précise qui est est ce que quand même
finalement on est bien sûr qu'on a fait
le tour du propriétaire suffisamment
alors pour répondre à cette question
vous allez voir quels sont les efforts
qu'ont fait les gens qui cherchent le
pétrole à la surface de la planète
alors vous avez ce genre de courbes très
intéressant qui vous donne en ordonner
les découvertes cumulé de pétrole en
milliards de barils et en abscisse le
nombre de puits d'exploration qui a été
foré dans une zone géographique donnée
donc là vous pouvez prendre par exemple
je pense que votre anglais est
absolument remarquable ici m e série de
visites dans queens orient ça c'est fort
moeurs soviet union donc c'est la russie
et les pays satellites kazakhstan
turkménistan et c'est un latine america
ou de riz arrivée africa aussi asie
aussi europe aussi et ça c'est notre
américain ici vous avez une évaluation
par la personne qui a fait le graphique
des réserves ultimes de ses diverses
journées
donc c'est comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure la totalité de la fraction
extractible des ressources en place y
compris ce qui est déjà sorti alors vous
remarqué que toutes ses courbes
elles ont tendance à avoir à peu près la
même tête giga à peu près la même tête
c'est à dire que elle monte au début
puis avec le temps elles ont tendance à
plafonner
c'est une autre manière de dire que les
découvertes marginal associé à un puits
d'exploration supplémentaires ont
tendance à baisser avec le temps sur les
pétroliers sont pas compris
fou une fois qu'ils ont fait leurs
échographies particulière à leur analyse
sismique
ils vont commencer par faire des trous
la wii pense que le prix du forage
d'exploration va ramener un max de blé
c'est à dire le plus de pétrole possible
découvert dans la zone dans laquelle il
fort et c'est bien ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui la majeure partie des
forages d'exploration qui sont faits
aujourd'hui sont pas faits pour
découvrir des gisements géants ils sont
faits pour aller gratter encore ce qui
reste à droite et à gauche parce que
c'est devenu économiquement rentable au
prix actuel du baril donc vous avez ce
genre de courbes un peu partout et vous
constatez que le fait de chercher plus
ne garantit pas de ce seul fait que vous
allez considérablement démultiplier le
pétrole découvert
donc on continue à chercher ça ramène
pas beaucoup plus de pétrole
alors vous avez une courbe qui à cette
échelle ici 120 peu curieuse qui est la
courbe verte duo dont vous vous dites là
est ce qu'on est bien sûr que alors la
voici avec une échelle qui est beaucoup
plus étalés et vous voyez que l'on
retrouve exactement la même forme et ça
ça concerne le moyen-orient ou au début
on a découvert quelques gisements géants
absolument extraordinaire dont dont une
bonne partie d'entre eux assurent encore
plus de la moitié des changes et en
assure encore plus de la moitié de la
production pétrolière du moyen-orient et
c'est deschamps qui ont 40 50 60 70 dans
les très vieux chant du coq lien mais
c'est encore de la pourtant que vient
l'essentiel du pétrole qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui donc les découvertes n'ont
pas baissé parce que on a arrêté de
creuser des trous c'est pas ça qui a
fait que on arrête
des coups de moins en moins les
découvertes n'ont pas non plus baisser
parce que les pétroliers sont des radins
et qu' ils gagnaient déjà tellement
d'argent comme ça que ils ont refusé de
faire des trous en fait le prix d'un
trou n'a pas cessé de croître depuis 25
ans et là dedans il n'y a pas seulement
l'effet d'aubaine dû au fait que les
parapétroliers c'est à dire les gens qui
font les équipements pour faire les
trous sont évidemment comme n'importe
quel commerçant avisé certes il ya
beaucoup de gens qui leur demande de
faire des trouvailles le prix des
croûtes
ça c'est ce qu'on est en train
d'observer actuellement mais c'est pas
seulement ça qui explique cette
évolution
et enfin si vous regardez la quantité
totale d'argent investi dans
l'exploration et bien elle a très
fortement crû ces dernières années et
c'était déjà le cas les années
précédentes
donc c'est pas l'une des idées qu'on
pourrait avoir naturellement comme
venant à l'esprit qui est ma foi on
découvre moins de pétrole tout
simplement parce qu'on se donne moins de
moyens pour en chercher comme par
exemple il y a aucune offre d'emploi
dans le pétrole qui arrive dans cette
noble écoles et bien pourrait constater
que c'est pas exactement le cas du reste
vous pourriez demander aux services ou
dans les carrières
c'est pas exactement le cas et en fait
c'est tout simplement parce que une fois
vous avez fait une fois deux fois trois
fois ou quatre fois le tour du
propriétaire
eh bien on commence à avoir une idée de
plus en plus affiné sur la quantité de
pétrole que vous avez sous terre
si vous essayez de faire un exercice qui
consiste à regarder ce que les
spécialistes de la question
10 sur la quantité totale de pétrole
extractives sous terre vous allez faire
très exactement ce que j'ai fait là
c'est à dire prendre un certain nombre
de publications techniques étalée dans
le temps donc des récentes puis des plus
vieilles 80 70 c est vous allez regarder
ce que les gens qui ont publié à
l'époque donnait comme évaluation pour
les réserves ultimes donc ici vous avez
un graphique qui vous compile le haut et
le bas de la fourchette pour un certain
nombre d'évaluations publié depuis les
années 70 sur la quantité totale de
pétrole extractives du sol y compris ce
qui a déjà été extraits et même tout ce
qu'ils valent dans la salle se rendront
compte que vous avez ici une courbe de
tendance qui est parfaitement plate
c'est à dire que la communauté
géologue au sens large il y à 35 ans
était ni plus ni moins optimistes
qu'aujourd'hui sur la quantité globale
de pétrole extractives sur terre l'ordre
de grandeur était parfaitement cerné ya
35 ans les géologues pétroliers n'ont
jamais dit qu'on allait manquer de
pétrole au nord de l'île jamais et ils
n'ont jamais dit non plus que nous
avions 40 ans de production si on les
cuisine est suffisamment à niveau
constant parce que c'est pas exactement
comme ça qu'il a résonné donc si vous
regardez ici la quantité totale encore
une fois de réserve ultime d'envoyer
elle est restée à peu près stable
un niveau qui se baladent quelque part
entre 2000 et 3000 milliards de barils
donc je vous rappelle que le baril
pardon j'aurais dû aussi vous exposer
ses unités
le baril est une unité particulièrement
exotique qui aime beaucoup les
pétroliers qui vont 159 litres
je vous ai dans l'énergie on adorera
utilisé dès lors les anglo saxons ils
sont champions pour ça ils ont pété eut
pas dans le système métrique arrive en
haut le long comme ça le british thermal
unit qui vont un peu plus de bejeweled
et rami jul vous avez de pieds cubes
vous avez le
galon vous avez c'était rapide baril 159
litres
bon voilà donc 2000 à 3000 milliards de
barils ça fait aux alentours si vous
prenez l'estimation médiane de 2500 à
peu près 350 milliards de tonnes donc ça
fait 35 ans que la médiane des
estimations ces 350 milliards de tonnes
de pétrole extractible depuis des
dizaines d'années depuis que je suis là
on n'arrête pas d'expliquer que les
réserves cross les réserves ultimes non
puisqu'elles sont intemporels par
définition les réserves prouvées
oui il n'y a absolument aucun
antagonisme entre jeu fait croître les
réserves prouvées et je fait décroître
les réserves ultimes restantes
il n'y a aucun organisme entre les deux
et je vais vous montrer et de manière
très simple comme je vous l ai dit tout
à l'heure le pétrole extractives de sur
terre il peut être dans trois réservoirs
il peut comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
monsieur de la palisse est déjà extrait
sur la chaussure qu'il est extractible
il peut être dans les réserves prouvées
cela je considère que je suis sûr qu'il
est extractible et puis il peut être
dans le reste c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je déclare pas encore je
suis absolument sûr qu'il ait
extractives mais demain je ne déclarerai
parce que j'aurai vérifier que il l'est
bien en 1970 on avait donc à peu près
350 milliards de tonnes en estimation
médiane de pétrole extractible sur terre
dont à peu près 70 étaient dans les
réserves prouvées et puis en 35 ans on a
fait passer le pétrole qui était contenu
là dedans dans les réserves prouvées
parce qu'on a développé les champs parce
qu'on avait des meilleurs moyens
d'évaluation parce que et c'est plus
vite ce qu'on a fait sortir le pétrole
des réserves prouvées vers la
consommation
donc vous avez un système avec 3
baignoire ou trois lavabo comme vous
voulez et il se trouve que la quantité
d'eau constante à quantité d'eau
constante dans les trois vous avez le
lavabo du milieu ou temporairement le
robinet est allé plus vite que la bonde
c'est tout et comme on a confondu le
tout et la partie depuis que il ya
publication de réserves prouvées parce
que ça aussi c'est un truc qu'il faut je
vous explique et bien tout le monde
pense que la quantité de pétrole
extractives à notre disposition ne fait
qu'augmenter
alors que dans la vraie vie
elle n'a fait que diminuer et là on
retourne sur le bon sens même si on
n'est pas paysan on comprend bien que
avec un stock initial de pétrole
extractives sur terre qui est ce qu'il
est il paraît assez difficile du pétrole
qui les 100 millions d'années à se
constituer il paraît assez difficile
d'avoir les stocks de pétrole à d'autres
dispositions qui augmente la
connaissance des stocks peut s'améliorer
les stocks même ils sont ce qu'ils sont
donc les réserves ultimes restantes
elles ont fortement diminué et toujours
pour l'anecdote
rappelez vous qu'on a qu'on n'a consommé
autant de pétrole entre 1980 et 2005 que
entre 1860 et 1980 ça c'est la magie des
exponentielle et dans le pétrole qui
reste une fraction beaucoup plus
importante est occupée par les réserves
prouvées que ce qu'on avait en 1970 en
1970 ses réserves prouvées occuper une
fraction minoritaire du pétrole
extractible restants aujourd'hui c'est
la fraction dominante et comme encore
une fois il n'ya que 7 ses réserves
prouvées qui sont connus du grand public
tout le monde a confondu la partie et le
tout et c'est imaginer que les ennuis
avec le pétrole était encore pendant
très longtemps alors que vous allez voir
que malheureusement c'est assez peu
vraisemblable qu'il en soit ainsi
vous avez par ailleurs un point de poker
menteur avec les réserves
la réserve comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure c'est une apparemment je vous
disais pas mais je vais vous le dire
c'est une appréciation subjective en
fait d'une réalité objective c'est ça la
réserve c'est j'apprécie de manière
subjective qu'elle est l'attraction
extractible dans l'objet que je suis en
train de regarder
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose pour
lequel deux personnes regardant le même
objet auront nécessairement le même avis
et par ailleurs le vous avez toujours
tendance à tricher un peu c'est à dire à
en enlever un petit peu de ce qu'est
vraiment extractif si ça vous arrange en
contexte actuel d'enlever un peu ou
aucun frères d'en rajouter un peu par
anticipation parce que vous savez que
vraisemblablement ça a toujours augmenté
au dessus dans les époques antérieures a
donc vous allez anticipé après ce truc
là et ont déclaré un petit peu plus tout
de suite alors voici un exemple donc
pardon je complète ça veut dire que la
réserve est nécessairement une
déclaration et en plus dans les réserves
il y à des déclarations qui sont sur la
place publique et des déclarations qui
ne sont pas sur la place publique dans
les déclarations qui sont sur la place
publique vous avez les réserves prouvées
des compagnies cotées dont vous appelez
total vous appelez shell vous appris
exxon vous avez l'obligation notamment
au titre d'un règlement de l'autorité de
bourse américaine de publier vos
réserves prouvées donc vous ne publiez
pas la totalité ce que vous avez
découvert vous ne publiez pas les
réserves ultimes dans ce que vous avez
découvert vous publiez vos réserves
prouvées encore prouvé c'est la seule
chose que le public connaît et puis
après vous avez des études internes dans
lesquelles vous avez vos réserves
ultimes avoué puis l'évaluation que vous
pouvez éventuellement avoir des réserves
ultimes des copains et de ce que
contient l'ensemble de la planète
il se trouve que la majeure partie des
opérateurs pétroliers
je vais vous le montrer juste après sont
des compagnons je vous montre tout de
suite je reviendrai à sartre est du
reste sont des compagnies publiques
c'est-à-dire détenus par des états et en
particulier les premières réserves de
pétrole au monde à peu près un quart des
réserves prouvées actuels sont détenus
par une compagnie et une seule qui ait
la compagnie nationale saoudienne qui
s'appelle la saudi aramco
retenez ce nom parce que dans pas très
longtemps je vais vous montrer un
graphique qui a été publiée par la
personne qui était en charge du
réservoir engineering de saudi aramco
c'est à dire la personne qui était
justement dans cette compagnie en charge
de l'évaluation des stocks de pétrole
sous terrain vous verrez que c'est
quelque chose qui mérite réflexion
donc saudi aramco à la première les
premières réserves
la compagnie iranienne vient en deuxième
position pour les réserves pétrolières
mondiales et du reste ceci explique
peut-être cela dans les relations du
monde occidental avec le président
iranien actuel de même que c'est des
gens qui ont une quantité de gaz assez
considérable ils ont les deuxièmes
réserves après la russie ensuite vous
avez les russes qui ont beaucoup de gaz
et très peu de pétrole etc dont vous
avez tout ça alors vous avez en ocre là
les compagnies nationales en bleu
les compagnies russes qui sont
officiellement privé et officieusement
probablement beaucoup plus nationale
qu'on ne le dit est la première
compagnie cotée qui fait partie de
celles dont on a l'habitude d'entendre
parler parce que c'est celle qui opèrent
en occident et celle qui distribue le
carburant en occident vous voyez la rue
à la 14e position et elle a des réserves
à sa disposition qui sont en gros 2 25
milliards de barils de pétrole
équivalent pascal gaz c'est à dire un
gros dixième un petit dixième pardon de
ce qu'ont les saoudiens donc l'essentiel
des réserves sont détenues par et des
plus pardon par des sociétés qui n'ont
aucune obligation de publication ou que
ce soit sauf en ce qui concerne les pays
de l'opep et ça va me ramener au
graphique précédent sauf en ce qui
concerne les pays de l'opep
parce que les quotas de production je
vous rappeler un tout petit peu ce que
c'est le pet sont proportionnelles aux
réserves prouvées
quand je vous dis ça je vais parce que
tout l'opep est un cartel de pays
producteurs qui s'est mis en place
si ma mémoire est bonne à la fin des
années 70 et qui avait donc d'un cartel
comme pour le rock viennent donc il
essaie jeu réguler le marché et l'idée
c'était de contrôler la production de
telle sorte que le pétrole est un juste
prix et d'éviter justement ce qui
s'était passé au moment des chocs
pétroliers afin d'avoir un
approvisionnement du marché qui
permettent d'équilibrer le budget de
l'arabie saoudite parce que c'est ça le
juste prix du pétrole quand on demande
au ministre saoudien du pétrole ali qui
a fait et pour autant sans avoir des
prix qui dégringole trop bas ou qui
montent trop au moment où l'opep s'est
mise en place
l'opep a décidé que la règle de
répartition de la production qui était
globalement limité en son sein donc
l'ensemble des pays de l'opep disait ou
fournir à temps et papus et bien la
règle de répartition au sein des pays de
l'opep s'étaient ont produit
proportionnellement aux réserves
prouvées nous sommes au moment du
contrôle choc dans les années 85 donc
les prix du pétrole sont en train de
dégringoler les budgets des
les producteurs sont restés ce qu'ils
sont et bien over night ou à peu près la
quasi totalité des pays de l'opep ont
réévalué leurs réserves
c'est abou dhabi par exemple a multiplié
les siennes par trois overnight voilà
comme ça de réserves prouvées x 3 alors
comme y'a que les gens qui travaillent
aujourd'hui chez schlumberger et chez
techni qui connaissent la vérité
la question c'est est-ce que ce truc là
c'est exactement ça c'est du bluff ou
est ce qu ils ont juste anticiper le
passage du 1 théo de paix dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure quand vous
demandez l'avis à monsieur al husseini
dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui
s'occupait du réservoir engineering chez
saudi aramco il vous dit il ya 300
milliards de barils
dans les 1200 milliards de barils de
réserves prouvées actuelle il ya 300
milliards de barils qui n'existe pas si
vous dis est-ce qu'il a tort est-ce
qu'il a raison vous et moi on n'en sait
rien personne au sein de cette salle de
s'est baladé dans le sous sol avec un
pied à coulisse pour savoir qu'ils
avaient tort et il avait raison
donc mais en tout cas le débat est
clairement posée et il n'est pas posée
entre un journaliste et claude allègre
dont il est posé entre des opérateurs
techniques du secteur
c'est important ce que je vous dis parce
qu'il est posée entre opérateurs
techniques du secteur
les gens extérieurs au secteur peuvent
raconter ce qu'ils veulent venir la
théorie du complot encore de beaux jours
devant elle mais par contre les
opérateurs techniques internes au
secteur ont pour le moment le plus grand
mal à y retrouver leur petit pour savoir
qui dit vrai qui dit faux dans cette
affaire où il n'ya pas de données
publiques communément accessible il n'y
a pas deux il ya pas de bases de données
mondiales centralisée et c'est très
difficile autrement que par de
l'espionnage industriel compris fort
cher que de savoir exactement ce que
produit le copain et combien il lui
reste et ça dur s-ata sera une énorme
différence avec le dossier du climat
dont je vous parlerai je dis parce que
en ce qui concerne la partie amont du
problème c'est à dire les réserves
chacun est obligé de travailler dans son
coin avec des propos à dire d'expert des
données confidentielles qu'il a réussi à
se procurer et c'est alors que dans le
domaine du climat
l'essentiel de la production
scientifique est sur la table est en
libre accès c'est une énorme différence
entre les deux ce qui veut dire que
n'importe qui dans domaine climatique
peut très facilement savoir de quoi il
retourne il suffit il empoigne de temps
alors que dans le domaine pétrolier même
en en prenant le temps ça reste très
difficile
il d'arriver à une vue d'ensemble est de
savoir si le pic encore une fois qui est
mathématiquement certain il est pour
l'année prochaine ou s'il est pendant 25
ans c'est extrêmement difficile d'avoir
la réponse à cette question
et pardon il faut quand même signifié
que signaler que la en 85 vous avez vu
tout à l'heure qu'on était sur la courbe
descendante et bien descendants des
découvertes
donc il n'y a pas eu de découverte
majeure qui juste ici le doublement ou
le triplement des réserves d'un certain
nombre de pays de l'opep depuis de même
que quelque chose qui pourrait paraître
très étonnant c'est que après vingt ans
de pompage croissant de pétrole les
réserves prouvées déclaré par ces braves
gens avec des découverts qu'en baisse
restent constantes
là il ya quelque chose vraiment la voir
ils ont peut-être raison
encore une fois ils ont peut-être
anticipé le passage du 1 p o de paix et
l'écart entre les deux est tel que ils
ont raison personne n'en sait rien
personne n'en sait rien dont je vous
disais tout à l'heure seules les
compagnies cotées ont l'obligation de
déclarer les réserves prouvées et les
états dans le cadre des accords de
l'opep
je vous ai parlé du pétrole et du gaz je
vais vous parler maintenant un tout
petit peu du charbon parce que quelque
chose que vous ne savez probablement pas
c'est que les premiers détenteurs de
ressources fossiles au sens large au
monde
c'est ni les saoudiens ni les iraniens
ce sont les américains les américains
ont les premières réserves de carbone
associées à de l'hydrogène que ce soit
solides liquides ou gazeux au monde ils
ne le doivent ni à leur pétrole ni alors
gaz ils le doivent à leur charbon dont
ils sont les premiers détenteurs de
réserves au monde et le deuxième
détenteur de ressources fossiles au
monde
c'est la russie qui est aussi le premier
détenteur de réserves gazières qui est
le deuxième détenteur de réserves
charbonnières et ces deux pays-là reste
les puissance énergétique dominante
même dans un monde dans lequel il ya une
dépendance au pétrole qui est très forte
vous montrez la dernière fois mais si
vous raisonnez hydrocarbures au sens
large quand ils regardent leur sens
large c'est clairement le qu'est ce que
je veux dire c'est clairement le les
états unis et la russie qui mènent la
course en tête et vous voyez que le
premier pays pétrogazier au monde c'est
à dire l'iran arrive à peu près au tiers
de ce que possède des états unis si vous
prenez si vous tenez compte du charbon
soit dit en passant je vous en parlerai
la prochaine fois mais retenez ça vous
avez je pense entendu parler du
protocole de kyoto
vous avez entendu parler de ces accords
qui ont été mises en place au plan
mondial pour essayer de limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et en
particulier du gaz carbonique
vous vous rappelez peut-être aussi que
on a l'habitude actuellement de désigner
du doigt un certain nombre de pays en
dix ans eux ils jouent pas le jeu 1c les
mauvais élèves de la cour de récré ils
font rien qu'à tricher alors qu'est ce
qu'on désigne souvent les états unis la
chine l'inde 2 qui s'agitent l'australie
de qui s'agit-il
des groupes et charbonnier retenez cela
le charbon reste une énergie rennes à la
surface de la planète
c'est ce que je vous ai dit la dernière
fois c'est la première source de
production électrique à la surface de la
planète et les pays qui ont refusé de
prendre les engagements contraignants
aux types de au titre de kyoto soit
qu'ils aient ratifié le protocole qui
n'avaient pas d'engagement contraignant
pour eux ce qui est le cas de la chine
de l'inde de l'australie par dont la
chine l'inde et l'afrique du sud soit
qu'il y avait des engagements
contraignants et ils n'ont pas ratifié
le protocole qui l'ont signé mais pas
ratifié pourrait faire un petit peu de
droit international la prochaine fois si
les savoir là dessus on fait 2 dans
lesquelles vous avez trouvé ce set dans
cette catégorie vous allez trouver par
dont les états unis et l'australie qui
est là et il ya un cas un peu
particulier qu'est la russie qui a finit
par le ratifier en traînant les pieds
mais vous voyez pourquoi il a traîné les
pieds simplement elle avait eu la chance
de connaître une grosse récession avant
donc ses émissions de co2 avaient
considérablement baissé
c'est des milliards de tonnes en
équivalent pétrole par don t au et
s'étonne oil équivalent ridicule a lancé
la tonne équivalent pétrole dont je vous
ai parlé la dernière fois c'était en
2006 en kilowattheures et j'essaie loger
deux gigas donc c'est les milliards
donc c'est des milliards de tonnes
équivalent pétrole je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que le canada possédaient
quelque chose de très particulier qu'on
appelle les sables bitumineux les sables
bitumineux c'est donc un pétrole plus
vieux du pétrole mélangé à du sable donc
ça s'exploite de la manière suivante
vous allez avec une grosse pelleteuse
prendre le contenu de ce que vous avez
dans le sol ou sous le sol vous mettez
ça dans une énorme chaudière est en gros
vous fait sortir avec de la vapeur
la fraction bitumineuse liquéfié à haute
température de ce truc là et après vous
avez un hydrocarbure lourd que vous
allez craquer raffiné auquel vous avez
rajouté l'hydrogène et c'est pire finir
par obtenir des trucs qui font avancer
les voitures et voler les avions si vous
regardez quelles sont les réserves
prouvées du canada en ce qui concerne
ces sables bitumineux
eh bien vous voyez que ça le met
quasiment au niveau de l'iran ou de
l'arabie saoudite
et là vous avez aussi une partie de
l'explication du revirement récent du
canada en ce qui concerne toujours ce
fameux protocole de kyoto c'est à dire
qu'avant il avait pris des engagements
contraignants
l'exploitation de ce truc là ça crache
plein de co2 ça ramène fin de dollars
qui sont des pétrodollars monde de l'art
et donc le canada aujourd'hui trahis
beaucoup plus les pieds commence à dire
oui peut-être que kyoto finalement
c'était pas une très bonne idée et c'est
enfin c'est surtout les gens du milieu
la seconde pétrole les québécois c'est
moins le cas
mais vous avez là une partie de
l'explication du revirement du canada
sur la scène diplomatique mondiale dans
le cadre des négociations climat
l'argent mène le monde
là comme ailleurs une fois que je vous
ai amplement parlé des réserves
maintenant on va se mettre à parler de
la production je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que
depuis la nuit des temps le journal
donne la production exactement le
pétrole restant en année de production
avec un effet monstrueusement délétère
qui est que à partir du moment où les
réserves représentent 40 fois la
production de l'adeic les ondes il ya
quarante ans de production et puis tel
qu'on est big horn et tous autant que
nous sommes entre le restaurant a
planifié pour ce soir les impôts à payer
etc
on réfléchit pas plus loin que ça et on
dit donc on est tranquille pour 40 ans
comme disait pumba d'un dessin animé du
funeste erreur
la bonne question la bonne question
n'est pas celle là
une réserve ne s'exprime pas en années
une réserve c'est un volume donc tout va
dépendre de la vitesse à laquelle vous
consommez votre stock et tout dépend de
la tête que va avoir votre courbe de
production et votre courbe de production
on sait aujourd'hui c'est dans le roi
lion pour ceux qui on peut peut-être
passer à la suite donc pour ceux surtout
faire un signe donc le la production je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'elle
allait obéir à un vieux théorème de
maths qui dit qu'elle allait passer par
un accueil par 2 0 elle passe par un
maximum mais elle tend vers zéro à
l'infini est toute la question c'est
qu'à partir du moment où vous avez une
idée des réserves ultimes sur un bastide
sur un bassin données est de savoir
quelle va être la tête de la courbe de
production et quand est-ce qu'elle va
passer par son maximum le premier à
avoir proposé une théorie en la matière
est un géologue américain qui a
probablement eu un coup de chance parce
qu'il avait proposé des tas d'autres
trucs qui s'appelle king du verte
donc on parle parfois pour le pic de
production du pétrole dont je rappelle
encore une fois au risque d'être
insistant que c'est une entité
mathématiquement certaines monsieur
hubert thil a fait le premier un
pronostic fiable sur le moment auquel ça
allait arriver aux états unis alors
pourquoi est ce qu'il a fait ça monsieur
hubert pourtant il a fait ça il a
constaté que sur le bassin sédimentaire
des états unis si on prenait les
découvertes annuel et qu'on les
approchaient tard une courbe en cloche
et bien on avait la forme générale 2
courbes de production qui allait suivre
qui avait exactement la même tête de
cloche sauf que c'était un peu décalé
dans le temps
en l'occurrence là le décalage il est à
peu près 40 ans monsieur hubert donc
dans les années 50 c'est à dire par ici
voilà tête de cette cour de production
jusqu'à cette année là et dit baye
savoir à peu près relate est découverte
par dont eddy la production va suivre un
peu près le même chemin et la production
va passer par un plafond aux états unis
en 1970 l'histoire a retenu son nom
parce que il se trouve que c'est très
exactement ce que ça fait mais enfin il
avait fait un pronostic juste un peu
avant où il avait prédit une autre année
et il sait prat mais bon ils tâtonnaient
sur un raisonnement général qui était
exact c'est à dire qu'elle est y avoir
un pic et il se trouve qu'à un moment il
a conduit un papier dans lequel il la
donnait effectivement il a donné la
bonne valeur et effectivement les
etats-unis sont passés par un pic de
production s'arrête à nantes un quart
d'heure c'est maintenant bon c'est pas
la gauche finit là dessus simplement
puis après on prendra la suite donc les
les etats-unis sont passés par le pic de
production l'année hubert avait dit que
ça arriverait et depuis effectivement
ils ont un déclin soutenue de leur
production pétrolière et avant la pause
je vais vous montrer le cas de la france
parce que vous savez que nous sommes un
pays extrêmement intéressant nous avons
un pour cent du pétrole que nous
consommons et 3 % du gaz que nous
consommons c'est ça la production
pétrolière la france et la production
gazière
dit autrement nous sommes à 100%
dépendant de la production pétrolière
étrangère ce qui vous explique pourquoi
il est si important d'être copain avec
poutine ahmadinejad et consorts en
france vous avez eu deux cycles de
découverte
vous avez eu un premier cycle dans les
années 60 et vous avez eu un deuxième
cycle dans les années 80 90 donc là on
n'est pas sur un dromadaire on est sur
un chapeau ne conçoit pas dans des
heurts avec les bédouins on a nos deux
bosses et bien east la courbe de
production du pétrole français qui a
déjà passé son pic
donc il ya au moins deux pays là vous
voyez qui ont passé leur pic de
production pour qui c'est une réalité
bien tangible
1 les etats-unis et la france est bien
là la courbe de production de la france
a eu
topic et cette structure en deux pick
est quelque chose qu après la pause on
va retrouver dans des tas d'autres pays
qui ont aussi connu un cycle
d'exploration avec deux pics et une
courbe de production avec deux pics donc
l'idée générale qu'il faut retenir c'est
que à cause du délai qui s'écoule
traditionnellement entre la date de la
découverte et la das de mise en
exploitation du champ à cause de la
manière de la langue la lenteur des
investissements que ces gros les
investissements domaine pétrolier
aujourd'hui les plateformes offshore
milliards de dollars le père c'est
ridicule à côté donc le vous avez d une
forme générale de la courbe de
production qui n'est pas très loin
d'avoir à peu près la même tête que la
courbe des découvertes avec un décalage
dans le temps voilà je vous en dis pas
plus maintenant je vous laisse en
suspens haletant et je vous dis alors un
quart d'heure